he is ESPN SportsCenter's senior anchor
he's Keith Oberman joining us from New
York City beautiful skyline there kayo
good to talk to you did you insist to be
called a senior anchor no as you know
from your own experience simple simple
explanation was I just started calling
myself oh it's like don't call yourself
that I said it's not in a row I'm not
trying to claim up in there consistently
since 1989 just sort of intermittently
I didn't know if it had to do with age
that you're a senior and that's why
you're a senior it's probably that as
well I hadn't gone through the math on
that and you know I mean the next my
competitor for this role and the person
who has it in terms of continuous
services Linda Cohen and the gentleman
does not ask the lady her age so I would
die I would say no I'm more senior than
Linda there's no doubt about well we
never got I don't think in trouble
calling ourselves to the Big Show by
management right we just had a couple
other shows the earlier Sports Center
that had a problem with us calling
ourselves the Big Show but I don't think
management was upset were they well you
may recall that that was the origin of
the ad campaign yes because they said
duh stop calling it the Big Show people
don't understand it's Sports Center it's
like you have a graphic over everybody
space there's a big sign and everything
says Sports Center an ESPN on it
why do how is it that that's not enough
we can't just sort of occasionally call
it no so that's then then the result was
okay this is Sports Center and the next
thing we knew they've been running the
same damn commercials for 35 years so
well not quite that long you know but we
got called in that was the infamous
meeting that we got called in upstairs
one of but that was the one where they
they were rattling the saber there that
was the most memorable one but that's
where they insisted we stop calling
ourselves the Big Show and Keith said we
don't know how many people are watching
we're kind of making fun of ourselves
calling ourselves the Big Show we're not
and then everybody took us seriously
you guys really think you're the big
show we go no we know the alternate was
the long show because if you recall when
we started using that phrase they had
just expanded every night's 11:00
o'clock show or 11:30 show to an hour
and my point in just starting having
come from the world directly at local
news for the preceding seven or eight
years I was used to you know
occasionally I'd do an hour half an hour
a postgame on a World Series on the
local station in LA something like that
but an hour of highlights and everything
changing at the last second as you know
and I may be the I don't know 15th or
16th commercial break we ever threw to I
turned to you and said Dan this is a big
women women's grow and yes yes it is and
I said I I feel like I'm going to call
it that at some point don't don't swear
so and then in this meeting you know we
get yelled at because you must call this
is SportsCenter
I think this better yeah and so Keith
said all right bleep um we're gonna say
this and we that night I remember we
finished the first 15 minutes the a
block and we went to break coming up on
the show blah blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah
this is SportsCenter and I go okay here
we go or variations of this SportsCenter
or this is and the rest is history
because when they came time to an
advertising campaign for the guys from
the guys from white and Kennedy said you
know what we really should call it this
is Sports Center and I was like and I
have as you I have received you know
zero but remember the Christmas gift we
got the cassette of the commercials well
that's much later I was thinking the
year we got the Ripken remember that the
Christmas gift for the entire company
was a VHS of my classmates Chris Berman
Pollock Oh
the Ripken game you know what I love
Chris and I've known him since 1971 but
this is the first VHS cassette I ever
had that unwrapped itself and jumped
into your VHS and hit play and was
already I mean and you hit mute in it
then it came out and unmuted all right
let me get to your field of expertise
which I wish this were happier
conversation okay when did you come to
the conclusion that there is zero
percent chance of the World Series being
played this year well I was still
holding out hope in March but really
since then it's been a slide downhill
and it's an accelerating slide down I
did this is just this morning's
headlines okay the top seven states in
terms of kovin spike in this country
California Texas Florida Pennsylvania
Arizona Georgia and Michigan that's
fourteen of the thirty teams play in
places where the disease is the worst at
the moment and this is by all measures
this isn't just oh we've got more tests
therefore we have more positive this is
hospitalizations this is people who are
really sicknesses people who are
asymptomatic all metrics percentage of
population percentage of positive tests
is out of control
14 of the 30 teams play in these states
and that's just the top seven you could
probably make a longer list in Texas
hospitalizations doubled in the last 18
days Florida's infections are five times
what they were two weeks ago 33 percent
of ER cases who show up for something
else like you know car incidences and
and overdoses and things they test
positive for it there's a Planet Fitness
in West Virginia one guy was positive
with symptoms on June 24th he was there
between 9 a.m. and 3 p.m.
205 people been told to quarantine for
the next 14 days and two of the older
Twins coaches have reported we've been
told to stay home because of their 66
and 68 years old they have health
histories that's just this morning and
we're still living in a world in which
for whatever reason and or whatever bail
entity you put to it or not this is
irrelevant to that you know gatherings
of 50 or more people are discouraged how
many people are going to be required to
put on a baseball game and yet even at
Yankee Stadium things
calm down here we're in good shape we've
all wore a mask so it really still wears
a mask and they do a pretty good job of
it except for some of the Millennials on
Friday nights because you can't drink
through the mask but the what are you
gonna do in Houston what are you gonna
do if somebody gets sick and not just
players but the support crew there's
going to be people cleaning the stadiums
and people cleaning off the locker rooms
the club houses where are they going to
go up there's no hospital bed the the
thing is so disastrous in potentiality
that I'm terrified by it in addition to
the idea that the what this is without
the idea of what happens if players get
sick what happens if players get sick
what happens if somebody gets a career
altering injury because it affects your
lungs and it can affect your organs and
you know the odds are pretty good
somebody young is gonna get sick but you
have leagues in Europe you know soccer
that are able to pull this off yeah and
in countries that have been you know go
outside without a mask and somebody
comes over and tells you to go back
inside and you know they haven't been
different protests there haven't been
riots about it there have been people
showing up with guns in capitals
demanding that they have the right to go
out you know just always think of it
this way if it were you stop thinking
about it as a disease but imagine it as
an invasion from another planet like in
Mars Attacks would you really be
demanding the right to go outside if the
government said hey listen they can't
find you if you're inside when you stay
inside watch TV it's the golden age of
television everybody you've ever heard
of has their own show and/or podcast
just watch for a little while they're
showing every baseball game ever
reported there's two no-hitters going on
my TV inside this window right now I got
hot the other day I had three channels
with Vin Scully on it this is this is
the golden time to stay inside now I'm
fortunate enough to have a balcony so I
you know I'm not one to speak about this
but that's the reason you know we really
did miss that the hint long ago it
should have been wear a mask and we'll
be able to have sports again this summer
but I just don't I don't know how it how
its proceeding and I end
I'm terrified having read this the thing
that really sent me over the edge was
the major league soccer protocols where
they're going to have the players all
sequestered and they're all already
connect to the game is gonna be in the
hotel at the complex in Florida and the
people who are gonna be bringing them
food and serving the meals of cleaning
the rooms they're not they go home every
night so they'll be commuting so the
bubble that the soccer players are in
it's not a bubble same thing with the
NBA Keith yeah you know is that is that
I've been trying to find out is that
what the NBA is doing everybody else in
the complex goes home at night yeah then
I took quite one class 45 years ago or
whatever the hell it was that touched on
pandemics and and diseases that spread
through a population and this is what I
remembering it which is you want to
avoid it you have to cut off possible
exposure to it and if you don't have a
full bubble you don't have any okay this
guy standing here but the guy standing
next to me at all that makes no sense
and and it's it's not going to work and
baseball doesn't even have any of that
they're gonna be people commuting
throughout this city to Yankee Stadium
not this metropolitan irradiate stadium
and then the Yankees are gonna get on a
plane at some point and go to and the
Mets are and every other team in the
majors and take whatever they have to
another city and this now takes us back
to where we were at the start of the of
March Madness if they went ahead with
March Madness the disease would have
been spread to Lord knows four hundred
other cities worth of germs and just
it's it's it sounds all of this sounds
to me like if you let management decide
not what's really good and safe for
everybody but to decide what looks good
and safe and that's you know that's its
marketing isn't it's it's a it's an
illusion of a bubble and I just think
there has and again if I'm wrong on this
I will come on every day if you want me
to and say hi I'm Keith I was wrong
about this good I'm glad I was wrong
about this I I would be I would be
delighted to be getting into the subway
or walking to Yankee Stadium
right now if that was what was required
to go see a game this afternoon rather
than talking to you I've been talking to
you since 1984 I don't need to talk to
you I'm wrong he is a senior anchor I
think that's what it's not senior it's
senior anchor that our broke my pencil
pen monthly ESPN SportsCenter's senior
anchor how do you think history is going
to view the Astros it depends really on
whether or not baseball is played today
this season honestly it's connected to
this because if there's no season there
only be two stories for the whole year
which was the failed attempt to get a
season going which will be summarized as
it was a failed attempt and 17 players
wound up in the hospital for six months
and the Astros those would be the
stories in 2020 if they play a season if
they get to a world series if I'm
completely wrong about that
the Astros thing will have been not
wiped from history but it will be less
of an urgency the thing about and we go
back and joke about the Ripken VHS tape
the thing about Cal Ripken and
everything that happened in baseball in
the aftermath of the strike and the
lockout and replacement players was not
that somehow those things didn't happen
but they were knocked off the front page
by Cal Ripken that's what he did and it
was it was the kind of thing where I
think people who like enjoy baseball
would love to have the Astros story
knocked off the front page and surely it
has been since the middle of March but
if they don't play any games this year
it'll be one of the two stories for 2020
in history will judge them as a slightly
in worse shape than say the 1951 Giants
because we found out contemporaneously
what they did and there's some proof of
it rather than basically everybody
everybody almost everybody was dead by
the time the real story of how the 1951
Giants cheated using a telescope and
signals from the outfield to make their
miracle comeback so it's something like
it'll be something like that a little
bit worse do you think it would be good
or bad for baseball the Astros were to
win this year I think you could get away
with it because there will always be and
I did a piece on this report center
sports history is what we decided is you
know the 18
89 Brooklyn Dodgers and one the American
Association of baseball league
championship that played in the World
Series the 1890 team moved to the
National League and played in the World
Series as pennant winners from the
National League the Dodgers view their
history is starting in 1890 they don't
count 1889 even though the same team of
the same players played in the same kind
of World Series only they changed
leagues we decide what it is we decide
what history is and you know it's like
Barry Bonds in San Francisco and and
that environment he's the all-time home
run hitter and everywhere else it's Hank
Aaron so history will decide what it is
this season is already open to complete
interpretations and you know as I said
that's under the best circumstances you
know it's it's it's it's a baseball
season for the original purpose of
having a baseball season which is to
provide the public service and we see it
more now than perhaps any of us living
as ever have has ever seen it great to
see you great to hear from you and we'll
we'll see how that 0.00% of a World
Series hey okay I only think there's a
50% chance that they open the camp's on
time next week so there you go you're
mr. percentage here yes well I I did I
took seventh grade math several times
well we're 100% done with the interview
though okay all right see in eight years
okay but Keith Olbermann's senior anchor
at ESPN